this is what the cyborg future looks
like
most everyone is enhanced with
technology many even surgically upgrade
their bodies with powerful bionics
computerized eye implants not only
sharpen Vision but immerse users in
seamless augmented reality
cognitive devices connect brains
directly to artificial intelligence
exponentially boosting intellectual
capacity
widespread machine integration is
redefining what it means to be human
my brain is melting today scientists are
blazing a trail to this very Future
these devices are going to make us more
powerful more independent
I want to know what breakthroughs are
being made it's a radio it captures your
thoughts in real time I'm improving the
human body by implanting devices into it
that will Forge the future too look ma
I'm a robot the cyborg Revolution
[Music]
my name is Angel jafria
I am a cyborg a combination of human and
machine that acts as one
I was born without part of my left arm
and I've been wearing a prosthetic
device as long as I can remember
they used to call me the bionic baby
this was my first ever
multi-articulating hand it was the big
jump from this one grip pattern
tripod to being able to change the grip
I flex the muscles unless we move the
hand
as my arm muscles move they affect two
electrodes resting on my skin which
allows me to control my bionic hand
four years ago I got my current
prosthetic hand and it's been a real
game changer
the finer motor movement in multiple
ways to grasp things
as someone who started to merge with a
machine I can see that it both defines
me and I Define it but I want to find
out how cyborg technology like this will
evolve for the entire human species how
far will the merging of man and machine
go
and what will our cyborg future look
like
[Music]
my first stop on this path to the future
is a personal one
at the Johns Hopkins Applied Physics lab
they are developing bionic limbs even
more advanced than mine
costing upwards of 120 million dollars
to develop the modular prosthetic limb
or MPL is state of the art
I'm really excited about today because
we get to see the MPL hand system which
is
something I've wanted to see for almost
a decade
I think I've dreamed about seeing this
hand
engineer Robert Armiger is combining
robotics neuroscience and artificial
intelligence to make devices that will
change lives around the world it's here
in real life that's right
unlike my prosthetic arm the MPL is
designed to be upgradable and it can be
customized it's also more dexterous you
know we've really tried to build in to
this hand all of the sort of movements
of the of the human hand so see that
each of the fingers is basically the
ability to separate or spread the
fingers here cool these two are coupled
together this one moves independently oh
okay all the fingers have a drive that
flexes each finger and then they've got
this mechanism that allows them to
passively curl around an object as well
that's cool I didn't know that existed
it even has a powered flexible wrist
I want flexion extension so badly
I don't have flexion extension I only
have rotation which is fun for a party
trick but I can't actually bend the
wrist so when I'm trying to put my hand
in my mouth and stuff I have to lift my
shoulder so when I see stuff like the
flexion extension in that wrist
it makes me really excited that I could
have it for my hand one day
[Music]
Bobby lets me test drive the MPL
first he places armband sensors on me
like my prosthetic arm these bands
contain electrodes which record and
translate the muscle activity in my
little arm we use electrodes that can
pick up what's called the bio potentials
of the human body it's sort of the
electricity that is flowing through your
body to send commands to and from your
brain
instead of just picking up like gross
muscles of these big muscle movements is
picking up smaller Finer Things today
I'm getting a feel for some novel
gestures and new capabilities all right
so when you're ready so you can start
recording no movement or rest state
and well that's okay it's it's learning
the first time so it may sort of confuse
what you're doing because it's never
seen this pattern before you're
introducing something new
a computer inside the MPL reads the
muscle movements from my arm and
translates these complex patterns into
movement in the robotic hand
this is really cool the machine is
learning more about me and fast so I'm
sending different muscles impulses like
to trying to see how much control I can
have over it of like the slow and fast
[Music]
I'll try to do this but
that's cool
this cyborg future emerged through the
needs of wounded veterans and other
amputees Johnny Matheny is one of the
individuals that we have spent probably
the most time with the modular
prosthetic limb and he has really been
able to show the capabilities of the arm
because he has a surgical procedure that
not only allows us to map the arm or
attach it directly to his body but then
he's had the nerves in his arm rewired
so that his control is natural and
intuitive
so what's next for it
fingertips are set up with active
sensors inside of each of the nodes what
we've been working towards is some of
the sensory feedback or stimulation to
your arms you'll be able to actually
feel with that the hand is touching
okay
my brain is melting without any feedback
from my prosthetic hand I can't tell how
hard I'm grasping an object I've been
holding a styrofoam cup or trying to
grab an egg right where you're like
don't crush it don't crush it don't
crush it don't crush it the team at
Johns Hopkins is working on this very
difficult problem
Bobby's colleague Dr Luke Osborne is
enhancing the mpl's features with
something called the E dermis
this incredible technology promises to
simulate the sensation of touch think
about how much we rely on our sensation
of touch not just for grabbing objects
but also interacting with other human
beings right yeah
edermis was made to mimic the way our
natural skin behaves and essentially we
have different layers and within those
different layers we have different
receptors inside the skin nerves detect
pressure pain heat stretch and vibration
the E dermis is made from flexible
fabric and rubber and inside of it tiny
sensors detect various stimuli and
translate them to the body's nerves
put it on on me or my prosthesis on your
prosthesis yeah
I've never really had that kind of
feelings on the side from like touch and
stuff so it's also like a little scary
but exciting when I press on your
fingertip I can see the activity on the
screen
so if you were to grab an object we
could see what the sensor activity would
look like if you were to naturally pick
up something
cool
Luke's computer displays the pressure
patterns from the e dermis for this
sensation of touch
when these same signals are transmitted
directly to my nerves it gives me a
sensation I've never felt before it
absolutely blows my mind and it's like
it's like falsely right here this is
really cool
I think seeing this just makes me
realize that
we're on the path of doing something
really really awesome things
I'll buy on a can with a fine sense of
touch will change lives and completely
reshape the future
the potential for this technology could
be not only used for rehabilitation but
also for projecting yourself into some
remote environment like a remote control
Iron Man Bobby imagines a future where
an arm like this could be used to
perform complex tasks from just about
anywhere
foreign
Advanced dexterous bionic arms are a
common feature on most robots
worker Bots perform complex and delicate
tasks in environments too hazardous for
humans from hundreds of miles away
skilled operators remotely perform
nuclear cleanups fight fires and even
repair the space station from the safety
of Earth
mechanically enhanced humans have long
been popular in sci-fi stories and
superhero comics
as a partial machine myself I'm excited
by the real superpowers that our cyborg
future will bring
but in everyday life making cyborg
technology work seamlessly with the
human body
is hard
when it comes to enhancing the human
body with technology balance is
essential weight speed strength these
are all factors that must be considered
when designing and Engineering wearable
robots at exobionics Jason Jones is
taking on the daunting challenge of
bringing man and machine into sync our
main purpose is to enhance human
capability through robotics primarily
right so either for medical purposes or
for industrial they've developed several
true to life exoskeletons in my lifetime
I think you'll see more of people being
augmented by machines the approach we're
taking is instead of replacing people
let's make it so they can do more if
they want to they can work in the older
age because they have enhancement
Jason's colleague Zach Hawes shows me
exactly how their exoskeletons boost
worker productivity this model is
already being used in factories see how
it feels I feel like I'm supposed to be
really really strong now right now that
I have the song This is designed to
really give sort of superhuman endurance
okay yeah I'll take that there you go so
now as you go to raise your arms you'll
feel it kick in yeah
oh okay yep yep feel it yep
and then what's it feel like like my
arms are like free-floating there you go
that's the key word there this
free-floating sensation happens with
mechanical spring driven technology
uses strain on the arms from repetitive
motion
so wild I can absolutely feel the power
and how it would transform industry
but for some it might be intimidating
do you think there's a little bit of
fear in the idea of like presenting some
of these Technologies yeah a little bit
of sort of you know there's just this
idea what what is this is the robot am I
a robot no am I working with a robot
what does that mean it's a machine that
we're now strapping to your body and
it's got to work with you and you've got
to work with it a little bit more
personal a little bit more personal so
yeah there's definitely more sense of
trepidation there but once people see
the benefits a lot of that disappears
pretty quickly
look Ma I'm a robot
not only do exoskeletons boost human
productivity they can also restore
Locomotion to those who've lost it I'm
gonna get to meet somebody who uses one
of these exoskeletons and has this whole
interface with technology like I do
Jess McNair experienced multiple strokes
and lost the ability
affected the right side of my body it
also affected my balance and vision
pretty severely it's been a journey
with the help of physical therapist Jen
mosiovich this exoskeleton is changing
Jess's future
[Music]
so cool can you explain to me what is
actually allowing you to do things
there's basically four Motors there's
Motors at the hips and then at the knees
and the ankle doesn't have a motor but
it actually allows us to position her
for greater balance that's really cool
so it allows someone to be fully
weight-bearing but also supported in a
frame in a proper biomechanical position
all right Jess do you want to start the
first step with the interface over there
[Music]
that's so cool
an onboard computer uses feedback from
sensors in the exoskeleton and
sophisticated algorithms process that
feedback and then apply the proper
amount of movement to each biomechanical
joint
this coordination of man and machine
represents a tremendous breakthrough
the exoskeleton is teaching Jess how to
improve her gait we want them to be able
to walk again we want them to be able to
step out of the device with a better
walking pattern
what do you hope to see in your lifetime
the goal is to make it smaller lighter
or more adapted to the human body and
less apparent so you want it to be like
more of a part part of you then exactly
yeah more Bionic
[Music]
exoskeletons like these have humble
Origins
early versions of this technology were
clunky at best and seemed laughable to
me today one may witness a scientific
Endeavor to convert a man's legs into
those of a giant
every evolutionary path must start
somewhere in our cyborg future is
advancing fast
[Music]
emit EXO would know they've also
developed exoskeletons to assist with
punishing physical outdoor tasks
carrying lard heavy loads over long
distances or increasing endurance that
kind of thing these powered exoskeletons
can help a person carry a 200 pound pack
swiftly across rugged terrain
incredibly the wearer would only feel a
mere fraction of that heavy weight
these here are hydraulic cylinders and
they basically are kind of like a
parallel muscle with the quads so you
can press down harder if you're walking
up a hill for example it will give you a
little application the design attempts
to amplify your Force right so if you're
applying a certain amount of force and
it would add to that to kind of offset
the effort that you're putting into it
that's really cool in the back you know
there's electronics in here and there's
a hydraulic pump and control systems and
then we talk about mud and Rain
obviously the electronics yeah the
challenges are they're pretty big
challenges I have those challenges
myself
future versions of this Cutting Edge
technology will someday be widespread I
think in the future you'll see many
people wearing assistive devices on a
daily basis I'm almost certain that
those devices will be controlled at some
level through interaction with the
human's nervous system or their brain
by enhancing our bodies with Advanced
robotic exoskeletons we're taking a step
closer to the cyborg Revolution
in the future miniaturized power
boosting exoskeletons are integrated
into custom garments with the Press of a
button superhuman strength and endurance
is available to everyone this body
augmentation reverses the decline of old
age restoring youthful vigor to anyone
who still has a passion to work or
explore
[Music]
in our cyborg future wearable machines
will augment our physical selves and
wearable computers will augment our
minds with instant access to Worlds of
information
I would wear wearables yeah how will
Advanced wearable computers impact the
way that people work learn and interact
with their world
to find out I've come to Atlanta to meet
a true Pioneer in wearable Computing bad
starter
for me the real killer application for
these wearable computers is augmented
memory machines that become part of your
mind give faster access to knowledge
make you stronger in the sense that you
have all this information you can use to
help you on your day-to-day life so this
was the first thing you worked on at MIT
right most people had no idea why you'd
want a mobile computer because laptops
weren't even out there yet
while attending MIT he became frustrated
by his inability to retain what he'd
learned in class so Thad built this
augmented memory system to take better
notes
are you ready oh I'm gonna put it on
[Music]
so bring your fingers around like this
there we go so now
now that is that is my daily suit in two
year 2000 so you'd have this plus a car
phone plus a seven pound lead acid
battery so I look really stylish
actually looks pretty good I tell you
the truth
though retro now that system had a
portable computer typing device and a
heads-up video display over one eye
found that once I had the ability to
take notes in class especially this
portable system I took notes in
person-to-person conversations and
that's one thing computers are horrible
at right now is assisting you during
this sort of interaction right
but having a hit-up display you only use
it when you need it and it keeps your
eyes in the world around you and I find
it to be really a good augmentation of
the conversation
the heads-up display overlays info
information within the user's field of
vision the system can be used to access
applications or the internet it can also
augment your surroundings with
information that only you can see
that eventually led a team that turned
this Tech into a commercial product
Google Glass
that's the first functional one
you add a glue a cell phone to the side
of our head to get a trackpad that
worked that's right and dance smart
glasses like these are making workers
more productive in Industries like
manufacturing and Healthcare
and it's easy to see why by beaming
information directly into the eye the
wearer can work on complex tasks all
while absorbing crucial information
hands-free it's actually lasers in the
side here that's bouncing off if you get
just right you can actually see a little
mirror here
kind of hard to see oh yeah it's good
yeah yep and so it bounces off the lens
and back into your eye that's so cool
breakthrough technology like this is
getting smaller every year even now it's
being developed for contact lenses
the Mojo lens is less bulky than smart
glasses and completely invisible to
others when paired with a smartphone
they not only display information for
the wearer but also improve eyesight in
the future we'll see the technology
disappear
they become widespread to bring man and
machine even closer into alignment that
is developing another cyborg technology
that actually teaches the body and brain
new skills with no training or practice
required this idea of being able to
passively train these skills is
something that's new we haven't heard of
it before these are what's called muscle
memory gloves and they teach you skills
like how to play a piano without your
active attention how does it simulator
what's happening okay so let me show you
let me show you the glove here
so what we got in here are little
vibrating Motors okay that are above the
fingers
sequence on my fingers this stimulates
and trains the muscles in my hand to do
something I've never done before play
the piano so she has a glove on right
now and what's doing is it's using the
vibration Motors to actually tap each
finger in the sequence of Beethoven's
oath to Joy you will have that muscle
memory in your brain I after the glove
has trained my hand for a half hour it's
time to see if it worked I don't play
the piano so this will be interesting
okay so let's take off the glove here
she's gonna put her hand down and we'll
see if she can do it we're kind of
excited to see what happens you're gonna
start there okay
so try your try your hand right
having never learned to play the piano
before I've gotten the hang of it pretty
quickly
by training the muscles in particular
ways these gloves rewire the brain
giving the user a jump start in
developing fine motor skills for just
about anything and we've been able to do
that not just for piano pieces but also
for things like typing for Braille
muscle memory gloves are already
changing lives one of the things we're
excited about is the rehabilitation side
of these gloves you can help people who
have had partial spinal cord injury like
this man the glove is even
rehabilitating muscle coordination for
people who've experienced Strokes you
can actually stimulate the hands such
that people regain some sensation or
dexterity I really believe that these on
body devices are going to make us more
powerful more independent wearables like
these that augment the mind and train
the body with new skills
a shirt and a cyborg future for all of
us
advance of complex surgeries to enhance
precision and dexterity
the devices are tailor programmed for
each procedure to passively train the
surgeon's hands
during the operation augmented reality
contact lenses provide a dynamic 3D
roadmap of the patient's body as a
result of these protocols success rates
are soaring above 98 percent
[Music]
sternal machines won't be enough to make
the merging of man and machine complete
will need to surgically integrate the
technology inside our bodies
to experience this integration myself
I'm outside Seattle to meet a
controversial biohacker he's offered to
implant a computer chip inside my body
I'd heard a lot about it from some other
people that I had met within
this transhumanist community which is
like a group of people who believe in
changing and upgrading your body
[Music]
like most transhumanists biohacker Amal
grafstra believes technology will
fundamentally change the human species
helping us evolve beyond our current
physical and mental limitations
I'm improving the human body by
implanting simple devices into it and
then and change my capabilities as a
human being that's biohacking
amol has turned himself into a lab rat
for his own inventions he has five
functional devices implanted across his
body
so those are implants these are implants
yeah so they would just go you take a
four gauge needle make a pocket and then
just slide it in okay cool there it is
so this is the new size of this
prototype this huge one yeah giant 35
millimeter diameter implant right that's
a big one oh that's a big one I've had
it for a while each chip serves a
particular purpose this is like a
payment card from the EU I'm converting
them into implants for people I'm
imagine that paying with the swipe of
your hand
but integrating machines into our bodies
has led to a lot of resistance
so from when you first started out do
you feel like people have gotten more
receptive
in general yes so in 2005 when I put
this in my left hand the first one the
reactions were very visceral what are
you doing they're crazy oh we should get
them you know like he's supporting the
government New World Order and now you
know you tell somebody on the street I
got a chicken but I was like oh I heard
about that however a society becomes
more receptive to the idea of cyborg
technology inside the body new ways of
using it will emerge
by incorporating magnets into his body
Amel has found that he's created an
entirely new biological faculty giving
him an unprecedented Sixth Sense
your magnet was able you were able to
feel the feel yeah magnetic field you
adapted to that but yeah you adapt to it
immediately and that to me again says
that this is part of who you are now the
implanted magnet rewired how his brain
and body experienced reality giving him
a new magnetic sense I took it out after
about a year and there was a real sense
of loss
amel's not the only one out there in
these uncharted waters cyborg artist
Neil Harbison has a cyborg antenna
implant which senses colors including
ultraviolet and infrared the implant
allows him to both feel and hear colors
as vibrations inside of his head
engineer Kevin Warwick had a chip
implanted in his arm that directly
connected his nervous system to the
Internet it's clear we are already on
the path towards the full integration of
man and machine
where do you think you know technology
is going in General on one hand it's
very exciting and Cutting Edge but also
it's nothing new like human beings have
always been leveraging technology since
we picked up rocks and sticks right it's
just that that technology has been
external the technology that's gone into
our bodies has always been kind of
medical and restorative right and this
is an enhancing you know augmentative
technology so there's some trepidation
about breaking the Skin Barrier for a
non-medical need right but overall the
trend for human beings is to make
technologies that enhance our
capabilities
with my bionic arm I know this to be
true firsthand but getting another
enhancement under my skin
I'm not so sure about you ready I am
yeah I'm ready okay the answer is yeah
the answer is yes okay good here we go
amol is implanting a Vivo key chip into
my fleshy hand take a big deep breath
here we go
[Music]
yay
this new implant will give me a unique
electronic signature
very cool
with it I'll be able to unlock all kinds
of devices and pay for things with a
simple swipe of my hand I think that
it's gonna be a point where everyone's
chipped at some point and there's going
to be something it might not all be the
same chip some people might have like a
glucose reader right some people might
have something else some people will
have a cognitive implant so the point
where we just put in our bodies and it
becomes part of who you are now yeah I
love
let's see if this thing actually works
so go ahead and press the button
and now back your hand across there
goes like that cool
integrating chips like these into the
human body will unlock doors to our
cyborg future
[Music]
size of a pinhead replace most wallets
and mobile phones everyone just swipes
their hands to pay unlock everything and
confirm personal identification the
magnetic sensor enhances orientation
operating like a compass it lets users
feel Direction no one ever gets lost
biosensors measure Vital Signs and blood
chemicals at the first sign of a health
issue Physicians are notified for
preemptive treatment
it's pretty easy to see how cyborg
technology can improve the body but
integrating it into the human brain is a
far more complicated and dangerous task
neuroscientist Dr John Donahue is
forging the difficult path to this very
future
we're in Providence to meet with Dr John
Donahue talking about implants like I
have the implant in my hand
[Music]
puts them in your brain
John led a pioneering team that created
one of the first brain computer
interface devices it's called brain game
we actually peer into the brain and look
at thinking about movement when we first
put an electrode in the brain we didn't
know whether somebody could control
anything
to decipher the connection between
thought and action John implanted the
brain gate device into Matt Nagel a
quadriplegic
[Music]
control a computer cursor directly with
his mind so the whole idea of a brain
computer interface is to help a person
who is paralyzed to be able to move
again or be able to communicate or
interact with the world
John achieved this Breakthrough by using
computers to read the brain signals
inside Matt's skull
the first technology to do this was
developed in the 1920s by German
psychiatrist hansberger he invented an
instrument he called the
electroencephalogram or EEG the device
measures the brain's electrical activity
through the skull and represents it as
complicated lines on a graph
however decoding these brainwave
patterns is an immense challenge
especially when the goal is to control
complex movement imagine that those
signals coming from your hand to control
that were not coming from your hand but
from your brain
and now you don't know what makes your
brain cells active so how can you relate
what your brain cells are doing to that
motion we didn't know whether anybody
could ever learn to do it with BrainGate
John took the next very difficult step
of deciphering a person's mental
intention to move their body
the first thing we have to do is we have
to go to a place in the brain that has
those signals then we need to be able to
sample the activity in the brain this
involves surgically implanting tiny
electrodes in the region of the brain
that controls movement the motor cortex
the electrodes directly observe and
measure the activity of the neurons
located there each neuron talks to lots
and lots of other brain cells other
neurons and it creates electrical
impulses that are the communication
language of the brain
each one influences the other and
collectively they generate patterns of
activity and the and the electrode array
is basically a hundred needles
oh my gosh
so each one of these is what the
electrode is recording and that is the
electrical impulse of the neuron
emitting its electrical impulse so we
actually aren't trying to interpret just
that cell all by itself but how does it
how everything works everything all
together it generates a pattern
understanding this pattern is like
putting together a thousand piece puzzle
without a picture for reference our job
is to take a look at all of those
activity patterns and try to make sense
of what they actually mean and what we
use as a computer to translate it is
really like translating a foreign
language and so what we do is when we
tell the computer basically when you see
the pattern that was recorded when the
person thought about moving with you see
that pattern again then move to the left
or move a computer cursor to the left
using artificial intelligence John can
translate those brain waves into a
physical action far more complex than
just moving a cursor
Kathy Hutchinson who was unable to move
or speak because of a stroke was the
first person to use brain gate to
control an external robotic arm and hand
this Leap Forward will change the lives
of countless people
but there's a big problem the
electronics required to amplify and
translate these brain waves are the size
of a washing machine
how will technology like this integrate
into the body to create a self-contained
cyborg
John has the beginnings of a solution
this wafer which is something like four
by eight millimeters it has one thousand
electrodes on it not but it's even
cooler that little square is equivalent
to ten of these things
all in a chip what do we need to do to
implant this into humans we have to
figure that out then we have to ask
users what do you want if it has to be
something sticking up like a box on your
head actually I worry that you would say
that's cool
but most people wouldn't want to do that
you know even though chips like these
are small they still need to connect to
external computers with a tangle of
wires given that Electronics can do this
that Neuroscience is not quite up there
but we're pretty good but all of that
information pulled together will get us
there we can do it this cyborg
Revolution
interfaces like this to read our most
complex thoughts and intentions
but making devices like this that stand
alone in the brain is not as far off as
one might think
in a nearby lab engineer arto nurmico is
developing tiny chips that will not only
interface with the brain but connect
wirelessly
so the first thing is to cut the cable
in order to particularly endow more
Mobility for a subject so he or she is
not Tethered to this massive right
volumes of electronics
he calls these prototypes neurograins
they look like glitter what they are are
individual tiny little chiplets about
the size of grain of salt each and they
have internal Electronics
there we go that's neurograin the
physical size means that there is safety
in implanting such tiny little objects
right in the brain without causing
damage thousands of neurograins could be
distributed across the surface of the
brain to record and broadcast neural
activity wirelessly each one of these
little triplets would be like a little
cell phone that's able to capture some
of these neural signals and then spew
them out streaming your thoughts in real
time
that's wild to think about
using computers Ardo is developing
cutting-edge techniques to interpret
these complex signals we use machine
learning to decode or understand what
those 10 000 little cell phones are
actually telling you or me about my
intention or your intention not only to
move an arm but perhaps do much more
complicated movements this same
technology could also be used like a
two-way radio not just sending but
receiving thoughts as well if we reject
forward and begin to contemplate or at
least imagine the possibility of using
electronic methods or communication with
the brain for people who don't have any
particular disability right enhancements
over restorative right exactly so that's
how the concept has taken its first
steps towards reality it's really cool
connecting the brain with machines
allowing a person to send and receive
thoughts would be a Monumental
breakthrough
[Music]
in the future brain implants replace
computers and connect wirelessly with
the internet
electronic communications like emails
and text messages are composed and sent
using thoughts alone
mental snapshots and dreams can be
uploaded to the cloud and shared with
friends every word in any language
written and spoken is directly
translated and accessible to any brain
now that humans off-source mental chores
like memorization the full potential of
the human brain is Unleashed
throughout human history so-called
psychics have claimed dubiously that
they can read people's minds
but as we blaze a trail to the cyborg
future reading thoughts aided by
technology seems more and more possible
but how would that kind of telepathy
work
I'm in Seattle to meet Dr Rajesh Rao
who's actually developing science-based
telepathy we began thinking about this
idea of extracting information from a
brain and send it to a different person
computer assisted telepathy brain to
brain communication this this radical
technology lets individuals use
computers to telepathically control
other people so what kind of reaction
have you gotten to your research do
people think it's cool or kind of scary
or all of that actually so you had
reactions ranging from you know it's
it's amazing it's cool it's so sci-fi to
people who are scared about this kind of
Technology
but when people adjust to the concept
is what the cyborg future will look like
are you ready to interface yeah I think
so and I'm going to give it a try you'll
be wearing a brain computer interface
cap that will be tapping into the
electrical signals that we are measuring
at your scalp which in turn reflects the
underlying brain activity
oh wow look at this room
rajesh's team fits me with a 32
electrode EEG cap the cap will observe
and measure the electrical activity of
my brain
all right right here
and I'll manage his wires
the computer reads the signals from the
EEG cap to interpret my intentions
does this look cool do I look cool oh
yeah yes it looks like you're from the
future even more so even more so I was
like yeah
my mission is to play a video game
through another person using
computer-assisted telepathy if this
works my brain will actually control the
other person's body
oh we're almost there Preston 11.
[Music]
I think we're good we're good yeah
quicker yeah
the video game at all so what we're
going to do is have you control the
cursor on a computer screen and that
message is going to be sent over to Jane
here so Jane will be receiving your
thoughts through this TMS transcranial
magnetic stimulation device yeah I'm
excited to feel your brain wave
all right let's figure this out
the TMS device uses pulses of magnetic
radiation to stimulate the neurons in
Jane's brain
it'll send a message to the motor cortex
region of her brain and that in turn
will cause her hand to move
an in turn it'll allow her to you know
play a computer game that she's not
seeing
let's see if this wild Contraption works
my goal is to use my thoughts to control
Jane's hand
if you want to send a yes signal just
pay attention to the left light and by
focusing on that the ball should move to
the corresponding Direction
by concentrating on the area of the
screen that says either yes or no I can
move the cursor left or right to
indicate my choice just by thinking
about it
when I select yes Jane will receive the
stimulation in her brain from the TMS
device to click her computer mouse
no stimulation
now it's time to see if I can send a
signal to Jane's brain just by thinking
and selecting yes
yes really yeah what did you feel
there's a little tap at the back of my
head and then my wrists and my fingers
just moved
using my thoughts alone
computer-assisted telepathy lets me
control another person's physical
movement I know I'm not thinking to move
it my hand just moves it's like a reflex
like when someone like kicks your knee
and it just moves that's what it feels
like that's so weird
Rajesh is using this technology to forge
a cyborg future even more mind-blowing
our goal is to connect brains together
such that the connected brains can solve
a problem that none of the brains
individually could solve networking the
minds of entire communities and
industries together could radically
transform society as the plan to have
more people to have like the whole net
kind of thing yeah so in the future
maybe you can unleash the kind of
creativity that a single person cannot
so by having many brains collaborate on
a project together perhaps you can solve
very hard problems
by networking brains with complementary
strengths the whole would be greater
than the sum of its parts and with this
kind of mind-melding cyborg Synergy
humankind might invent new forms of
green energy and reverse global warming
decipher the mysteries of human
consciousness or even answer the
question of what happened before the Big
Bang
the sky is no longer the limit
but with any new and disruptive
Technologies Society needs to weigh the
benefits against the risks how cyborg
technology will change the world is
unpredictable
as with any device you know we need to
look at the privacy and safety issues
more so in the case of brain computer
interfaces because it has the potential
to change who you are
it's easy to take for granted that the
contents of our brains belong to us but
in the cyborg future that might not be
the case that personal private
information that makes every person
unique could potentially be abused in
this world of neurotechnologies Ethics
is hugely important you could call The
Invasion or your brain as being the
ultimate sacrifice or ultimate leap or
you could say well it's just another
increment in the pathway of losing the
ultimate privacy which is the privacy of
your own thoughts
and in the future who will benefit from
things like cognitive enhancement will
the privilege be the only ones that can
afford to download a lifetime of
learning into their children's brains
or will everyone gain access
the cyborg revolution has the potential
to upend society
but many are excited about the
transformative possibilities of a cyborg
Future Let's imagine we're linked nearly
right we lose the language completely
and now it's just thoughts and feelings
and Concepts and like who knows right so
it could definitely fundamentally change
Humanity I really believe that this
technology can when it becomes part of
us
make us more of what we really are which
is human
sirens hopeful that science
as for me I expect everyone will become
a cyborg one day and I can see a future
where individuals choose to upgrade
their physical body parts with robotic
ones once they have better features the
cyborg Revolution is coming and as a
cyborg myself I couldn't be more excited
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]